The little prince
has really come
to like this little body
that's orbiting him.
He knows at what
distance it orbits
and knows how fast it goes.
And I think the little
prince fell in love
with that little body.
And now he wants to
see it all the time
as it goes around the asteroid.
But the little prince just
wants to keep sitting there.
He doesn't want to move.
So how fast does
the asteroid need
to rotate so that the little
prince will always see the body
as it rotates around him?
Well, for that, we
need to simply consider
that the period of the little
body going around the asteroid
needs to be the same as the
asteroid rotation period.
So we're going to call
that Ta for asteroid.
And well, if we want to know at
what distance that works out,
then we're going to use
Kepler's laws here again.
And we're going to
have that the radius
between the body
and the asteroid
will be Gm1 over 4 pi squared.
And now we have Ta squared in
here and the third of that.
So all of these
wonderful quantities
make the little
prince really happy.